[Music]
hello in a very warm welcome indeed to
this latest edition of quadriga well we
are this week focusing on the handover
of power at the top of American politics
from Barack Obama to Donald Trump now in
recent days the battle over President
Obama's legacy has been heating up the
man who came into power eight years ago
promising to bring sweeping change to
the United States has this week been
defending his record in an emotional
address to his followers in Chicago
meanwhile however it looks as though
Donald Trump is set to take a wrecking
ball to most if not all of what Obama
has stood for so our question on
quadriga this week is Obama's legacy can
it survive Trump and to discuss that
question I'm joined here in the studio
by three seasoned commentators let me
introduce them to you beginning with
christoph von Mashhad a senior editor at
the berlin daily der Tagesspiegel
christophe argues that the world will
very soon come to miss barack obama's
thoughtful approach to politics as he
puts it and also with us is Alan Posner
a regular commentator for another Berlin
based newspaper deep-felt
his opinion Trump is Obama's legacy and
we're joined by Melissa
Eddie Berlin correspondent for The New
York Times who says Obama wrote history
as the first black US president even
Donald Trump can't change that well
Melissa I'd like to begin with you we've
seen Barack Obama giving his farewell
address this week I wonder how much
you're gonna miss him a lot it's it's
hard to quantify the difference is so
between when you watch Obama's speech
any watch Trump's press conference the
difference in in the personalities and
what they stand for is just it's
palpable it's it's so obvious and I am a
person who cares about language cares
about the use of language and I have to
say there was something thrilling about
having a president who could actually
hold a speech and hold a huge crowd
riveted and the speech felt like like a
delivery of a message and not like a pep
rally for a sporting event okay we know
Barrack Obama can deliver a good address
but what about what about his policies
is is there a coherent body of
achievement
that can be described as obama ism in
terms of policy well you know the
biggest one i would say would be the
healthcare policy which of course is
what the republicans are intent on
taking a wrecking ball to which i think
is going to be real test of where the
country is that we will see the
republicans are saying that they will
replace it
they will take down or take apart
obamacare but replace it with something
better at this point however they've not
said what that something better is so
everyone is still waiting they're very
intent on the taking apart but i think
everyone knows it's easier to tear
something down than it is to build
something up and it's it's really going
to be a test to see what what that means
for people and and will people be
willing to give up something that for a
lot of people they've come to understand
and you know you don't need to explain
to anybody in in germany or most of the
rest of the world what it means to have
health care but i have a lot of friends
from my generation who work as
freelancers or went from job to job or
had low-paying jobs and until Obama
brought in the Affordable Care Act also
known as Obamacare they never had health
insurance
kristef on marshmallow you you're a
former US correspondent you've been bit
of you've been up close to Barack Obama
the man we're talking about I know and
you say the world will very soon come to
miss President Obama's thoughtful
approach to politics what makes you so
sure
yeah well as Melissa said we sought two
different characters in the speech of
Barack Obama on Tuesday night and then
the press conference of Donald Trump I
mean he saw and pull so if he's reacting
at everything he seems to treat
everybody as an enemy or friend mainly
enemy and when he feels hit he has to
hit back that is not the approach of
Barack Obama I generally think that
Barack Obama will be seen as a great as
a good and great president from the
perspective of history it's not only
that he inherited from Bush country in a
deep recession where unemployment was
growing people lost their homes at a at
a very quick pace and today America is
engross again we have a very low
unemployment rate of course is this not
true for every region in the United
States so I understand why they
this protest and opposition moon but
apart from coming from recession to
growth it see health care reform it's
the reform of the financial system he
nominated two female Supreme Court
justices the first Latina he changed how
the country thinks about homosexual love
gay lesbian and so and so on he had a
huge well the missile contract was
Russia to delete one third of all
strategic missiles I could go on going
Barack Obama himself defending his
defending his record I'm just there's a
darker side to all this though I mean
you said at the beginning of the show
Alan or at least I quoted you are saying
that that Trump is Obama's legacy
explain well first of all Obama if you
say you're delivering change we can
believe in and you don't deliver change
in spite of what you've said about Obama
care in spite of the fact yes there's a
certain amount of recovery that for huge
sways of the American population
especially of course the white male
underclass you're not delivering what
you promised but also not for the blacks
we've had the black lives matter show
that that wasn't delivered and that's
why they didn't turn out for more of the
same change at the election and while
they didn't turn out for Hillary was
just a you know gonna be Obama too and
if you look at foreign policy America is
perceived in the whole world as weak
incredibly weak including in Europe
we're worried now about you know is
America gonna defend us Putin has walked
roughshod over every red line Obama has
drawn Obama lost the Arab world in the
air abelian Obama a lost Israel lost
Turkey I mean I could go on and on as
mr. Marshall has been going on about the
decrease of America's standing in the
world and this is due to the fact that
he
was Obama was a great orator he was a
first-class intellect but a second class
temperament you remember of Franklin
Roosevelt once said what some person as
a Supreme Court judge said he's a second
thousand she liked but a first class
temperament Obama's got a great
intellect he can talk the talk he
couldn't walk the walk and there's a big
difference and after years I think you
cannot forget how tired many Americans
are of being the world police that from
the public there's a certain desire and
a push back you know we're tired of
seeing our young men battered on foreign
on foreign battlefields yeah this was
something that's why he's getting all
these votes why but but to what extent
is that the president and what extent is
he listening to his people and where the
rest of the world may not like that
although you know we can argue does the
world really want to the United States
is the world police yeah oh yeah it's
you know it goes back and forth but I
think domestically there has been a
shift and the desire from within America
to play the world police that is not
their the way it was before
okay mark on the foreign if you are
afraid of the weakness of America under
Obama then be more afraid when I hand
when it comes to Trump I guess it's
gonna get worse I'm waiting for the
moment when countries like North Korea
like Iran like what are really
challenging him and then it will turn
out that you can say a lot of oh we will
be great again but he he will not be
great and he will have no answer and I'm
saying Trump is even worse but my okay
the rot started exactly as you say when
Obama started listening to Americans
instead of convincing them that America
needed to lead in its own interest this
idea nation-building begins at home that
could be Trump's those could be Trump's
words and it's wrong they don't
nation-building does not begin at home
if you're the words leak world's leading
power you have to keep on building
nations and alliances all around the
world and Obama neglected that let's
just let's just go back a little bit in
time before we continue to talk about is
like I said just like to go back to 2008
the very early days the the campaign for
the presidency the first days in the
president
for Barack Obama 2008 as I say we can
see examples here of his rhetorical
capacities in his great charisma yes we
King Barack Obama America's first
afro-american president many hoped he
would unite a divided nation Obama could
create the proper atmosphere for any
situation
Oh bomber was also popular overseas even
before he was elected he drew huge
crowds in Berlin during a visit in July
2008 Barack Obama and his wife Michelle
made a good team and served as positive
role models for many Americans it was a
dignified farewell but in the final
analysis how will history judge Barack
Obama's legacy that's the question
Christopher Allen is basically saying
that yes Barack Obama has this huge
talent he's still a very young man by
the way we don't know what he's gonna do
with it but that he has squandered his
talent I don't think so I mean I of
course he he is not all fine he also had
a lot of mistakes and in foreign policy
I would say his biggest was Syria not
that he didn't went in I think that was
very wise but drawing red lines and not
doing anything when somebody crosses
your red lines that is a big mistake and
generally I would say the Barack Obama
as what what what what he leaves behind
is his foreign policy is much more mixed
records and a domestic policy in
domestic policy you can say well I'm on
his side or on I'm on the other side I
think the state should be responsible
also for the well-being and the social
welfare of people or not and then you
have a clear point but in in foreign
policy is much more mixed but I think we
we shouldn't just the mark is not is
something worse in the world
before so it must be his fault there are
a lot of other players and I would agree
that he made mistakes but generally how
he handled Europe how he handled China
that he also left it to the Europeans to
deal with Ukraine for example I think
that was all wise and and clever and
good and in a certain way he was
reliable and he was predictable and that
is an enormous ly important for the
security of the world that important
players are predictable and are reliable
and that is a big danger what is coming
after him that is that as a change a
change I don't want to believe him hmm
how is it gonna change I mean what's
gonna have what were there I mean the
big question that we're debating here
and now is you know what what happens
next what is what is president-elect
Trump what is President Trump we don't
know yeah why don't we know the most
powerful man on earth is about to be
inaugurated in office in there in a
couple of days time we don't know what
he's gonna do next
he has zero foreign policy track record
you know even though there were
comparisons to Reagan beforehand before
Trump became into office people were
saying oh well look Reagan this Reagan
spent eight years as a governor of a
state that is larger than more than half
of the European Union member states the
state of California he had a certain
track record Trump comes in with
absolutely no track record for foreign
policy and he's a businessman and
therefore I can't say what he's going to
do it I had well you know I think are
you dismayed by this are you two a as an
American citizen are you are you are
nerved by this it's a it's a it's an
unsettling scenario settling scenario
but I think from German from the German
perspective it's sometimes hard to
understand what the world looks like
from the Midwest when you're sitting in
the middle of the United States of
America which is an enormous country New
York or Washington DC seems really far
away and the idea of building nations
States you know when you have bridges
literally collapsing in your own country
that's Obama isn't it the idea it's not
actually it's
repair stuff for eight years well look i
mean i think it's not it's just not true
that we don't know what what what
Trump's gonna do we know and it's scary
he's gonna revert to economic
nationalism he's gonna put America is
gonna put America first he's gonna raise
tariffs on imports and he's gonna by
hook or crook create jobs he's not gonna
dismantle Obama casts well you'll
dismantle Obamacare but probably more
people will get her health insurance
because that's gonna give him give him
votes is it's all gonna be about America
first American jobs first and he's gonna
do that you know but twisting arms like
he's already done with Ford with the
whole American economy putting up
tariffs it's gonna be disastrous it's
already the Europeans who were so
against the transit Lange trade an
investment project are going to be you
know begging America to bring it back in
and it won't happen and you know and
this is part of the legacy for Obama so
Obama is trying to do something like the
transatlantic trade and the Europeans
were all throwing up their hands saying
oh this is terrible this is terrible we
don't want this pushback and and part of
Obama's legacy is not getting that
through well that's the European legacy
quite frankly because so also also but I
mean Obama was not the one putting the
brakes on that yes he was actually
because he didn't there was perfectly
legitimate European concerns about the
question of how you had to go about if
there are conflicts of interest between
American investors and so on and
Americans didn't budge enough because
Obama had for years the second hole
America the hole second time of Obama
was about TTIP as far as Europe as
current he didn't push enough and that's
the whole point he was too much of
someone who was aloof from the process
and this has cost him friends and
Europe's it cost him friends in the
United States it's the opposite of what
Franklin Roosevelt did who went out and
found allies for what he wanted to do
and told the people about it and this is
the problem of this aloofness I'm
concerned about something totally else
my my concern is not that yes Donald
Trump he has a clear plan and he will
get it through hundred percent and steam
know there are so many lines
lines between the Republicans in
Congress and him he will not get some
money to have a huge infrastructural
program he will not get the money to to
keep subsidies to American firms that
say create jobs in the United States
instead of abroad that's not gonna
happen because they are deficit hawks
what I'm really concerned about is is
this in predictability and we just saw
it in the press conference the day of
the press conference could you imagine
that we talked about a memo in Russia
that maybe President Obama had meeting
with prostitutes in a Moscow hotel I
just like to ask my producer can we can
we put up some pictures from that that
press conference that took place on
Wednesday at Trump Tower in in New York
it was the first press conference that
president-elect Trump had given in five
and a half months I think six months
here we see him in action Chris off sir
I just wanted to get those pitches up
while you're talking yeah okay so I
don't know at all whether this is true
or is it just invented by the Russian
again in order to steer and uncertainty
about our values about the value of
democracy and so on we don't know that
and we should repeat and repeat that
this is not sure is that we don't know
about it whether that's true or not but
just imagine it could be true that
members of Donald Trump's campaign team
during the campaign against Hillary
Clinton met with Russians in order to
sabotage the u.s. election process I
mean that would be treason if it's true
that would end that what shortcut the
Obama presidency the do you believe it
is true is your news paid off by the
Turkish speaker believe that is tricky
no we don't know we don't know at all
how exactly are you handling the
allegations we we have to report it but
we rather repeat free reporting them
salaciously or extremely cautiously I've
seen I've seen sectors of the German
media have been reporting the greatest
did the most graphic detail no no very
cautiously and also with the hint that
we don't know whether this is just
Russian clamped or
it's really true it is if it could be
true but just that shows you what
enormous change we have in the United
States at the moment going on it was not
we couldn't even imagine that something
like that happens under President Barack
Obama and it tells you something about
his values his characters how he acts
and even for example some things we all
know the other thing that we have to
that we have to keep in mind is we you
were absolutely correct we do not know
if this is true but if we look at the
reason why its surfaced Trump even
before he has taken the oath of office
has been at war with his secret security
services this document according to my
colleagues in Washington has been around
for a while people have reporters have
known of his its existence but nobody
dared touch it because we do still do
not know we did not know and we still do
not know if it was true but the moment
that the security services briefed Trump
and Obama about it it has given a
legitimacy to the document and the fact
that the security services would take
that step also is for me personally very
unnerving because it's almost you know
it seems that even now within his own
administration there are terrible fault
lines and we did not see this under
Obama we saw the terrible fault lines
between the Democrats and and the
Republicans in Congress but within the
administration there was cohesion and
there are already signs that that is not
going to be the case and if the
administration cannot function as a
whole then that I find that deeply
troubling hmm let me just ask you one
more thing you do all fascinating stuff
I just like to we saw this press
conference yesterday I for me it was a
watershed event I just like to ask you
what other because you said we don't
know where Trump is gonna take the
nation next we don't know what Trump is
immersed and for what clues did you get
yesterday what further clues I have to
say I was in meetings all day yesterday
and I have not had time to sit down and
actually watch watch the press
conference
I've read about it I've read our reports
not because I'm fascinated to know we
know what's gonna happen next anything I
want
more well as I said I think Trump as a
personalized idea about politics he
thinks you could do politics like you
can do business and we know that from
Silvio Berlusconi in Italy the this idea
that a businessman knows how to do
politics better which is stupid quite
frankly you know business is I make the
decisions you do it and so on but the
point is that given the the axe to use a
German word going around in Washington
among Congress people I think the kind
of wheeling dealing arm-twisting that
Trump is so good at in business might
work for one or two years in politics I
think after that is gonna run against a
whole lot of brick walls and if he does
manage to raise yeah and then it's gonna
be really horrible for the US economy
but you might just see a trump recovery
happening under the augury of economic
nationalism and and that's you know and
when he does and that's what I think
that's what's gonna happen it's gonna
happen so and he he said I'm appointed
so and so I'm pointing so it was all
about men not women basically men he's
appointed to do this to do that and
he'll get these people in a room
together he's gonna say I'm gonna give
you this you're gonna give me that and
he's gonna do deals and I think the
terrible thing is it's gonna work for
one or two years and we're gonna see if
the dollar rising we're gonna see jobs
being created we're gonna see people
saying you see even in the German media
the the far-right is rallying to Trump
and they're saying why don't we do the
same we can only hope that he runs up
against the war before Europe starts
doing the same thing okay when you talk
about the German media I just like to
move the debate closer to Germany and
bring in some bringing some images that
I we've got of the last meeting I think
it was the last meeting between
Chancellor Merkel and and President
Obama there you go at the g7 summit in
Bavaria last summer
folkloristic seems almost but signs of a
great understanding between the two
leaders there's also that famous shot
where they were sitting out in the
meadow there you go
I just like to us christophe as an
expert on foreign policy what you
anticipate we're going to see were the
first time that Angela Merkel and Donald
Trump come face to face they will try to
get along with each other it is
impractical but also responsibility I
mean it is pretty clear that a lot
depends on whether Germany is the most
important country in Europe and the
United States get along pretty well
our security depends on it I mean all
all the terrorist threats in Germany if
we have somebody who really gives us
important hints it's not the Russians
it's not the French it's not our own B
and D it's mainly the Americans so
that's also insane and sensible the
president-elect Trump has has been
showing abject disrespect for NATO for
example no not so second sensible but
but the German approach was this problem
or this challenge will be that we tried
to get our arms around him to pull him
in in our understanding how he should
treat NATO why NATO still matters to us
I'm more concerned that the Trump
presidency will be early derailed by
foreign challenges and by his because he
is so combative
in the in the in the inside not you need
to have sort of coalition building a
political coalition building in order to
act it is a very common thing that
normally when people are running for
office they tell you what they want to
do and then they get into office and you
think now they will try to push their
programs who but they will be derailed
because so many things happen from the
outside which they can't control we will
see since President Trump from the
beginning will look somehow somehow weak
or not sure about what's what's going on
see North Koreans will challenge him the
Iranians will challenge him the Russians
will challenge him and he is all the
time to react he has all the time to
react and can't push his programs
through and that is a huge risk
I don't wish that for the United States
I don't wish it for us because we will
feel
see consequences as well I don't wish
that his presidency will be derailed but
I'm afraid that it the risk is very high
is that it happens soon Melissa
30 seconds your thoughts on the same
matters I agree going to talk sense into
Donald Trump even if you think of when
she and Obama first met they were sort
of oil and water and and and like a
couple of posing magnets and eventually
they came around and and found a way
towards each other some of that was
Obama approaching her but I think I
think Trump will also look first trying
to make a deal with Merkel okay final
question that was the question of the
day will the Obama legacy survive Trump
yes or no most of it most of it
Melissa I agree that yes what he
represented and what he stood for for a
generation will all true oh no it's gone
we're facing really bad times we're
facing really bad times and on that on
that thoughtful note from Hallett pose
and I'll say thank you to Christophe and
Melissa as well and thanks very much to
you for joining us if you've enjoyed the
show as much as I have do come back next
week until then bye-bye just
[Music]